let's take some more calls six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty is
the number who's our next caller
hello yes you're on the air what's your
name where you calling from hi my name
is Thomas Hathaway I'm coming from
college from Alberta Canada and I was
just wondering if you believe there is
any clarification between the hate
speech and free speech in the United
States if there's any clarification or
any distinction I want to make sure I
understand the question correctly if
there is any distinction between hate
speech and free speech well yes I mean
that the two term we're talking about
two different things so free speech is a
constitutionally protected concept as
established by the First Amendment hate
speech is a legally defined term that
relates to incitement to violence
threats etc so I think that there's
certainly a distinction we're talking
about to two very different concepts so
do you believe that there should be
protections against hate speech in the
United States yes there should I mean
you can't go out there there are certain
types of speech that are not just free
speech that they actually have an impact
that can be a violent impact they can be
an impact that concerns the criminal
justice system they can be an impact
that leads to other repercussions where
we can't just say hey listen you can go
and stand in front of someone and start
hurling threats of violence in an
intimidate or E way that is something
that the legal system and law
enforcement has an interest in
protecting people from and that's very
different in my mind than for example
the constitutionally protected right to
burn a flag for example yeah so true
enough it's a lot like it is it's gonna
be a lot like it is in Canada then yeah
cool
uh-huh thank you you're wonderful thank
you so much I really appreciate the call
always good to talk to people in our
friendly neighbors to the north